non je suis très normale c'est très
ennuyée peut-être
Johnny Depp mais moi personnellement je
trouve ça bien
c'est vrai
c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment ça
faisait un moment qu'on avait pas vu
Vanessa Paradis on est très heureux de
très heureux de vous voir Vanessa alors
lors de notre première rencontre c'était
en 1987 c'était au bain douche
l'émission s'appelait bain de minuit
c'était l'année de Joe le taxi et les
paroles de la chanson étaient détiennent
rhodagyl Étienne Roda Gilles qui nous a
quitté récemment et pour qui je voudrais
qu'on ait une pensée parce que c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait important pour
nous et pour vous ou alors du commun
vraiment un type exceptionnel on l'a pas
dit ici au moment où ça s'est passé
parce que c'était comme ça et ce soir je
suis ravi de lui rendre hommage en mode
compagnie Vanessa
Étienne si tu nous regardes comme dit
Drucker on me dit qu'il regarde Arte qui
Étienne
absence au cinéma donc le temps de faire
deux enfants Lily-Rose et Jack le temps
d'un CD qui s'appelle Bliss et d'une
tournée vous revenez dans un film
absolument barjo une comédie de
science-fiction qui s'appelle atomique
Circus le retour de James bataille des
frères Poirot alors c'est un film
ovniask c'est complètement un pitchable
c'est une série Z déjantée ça se passe
dans un village qui s'appelle
scotlet City un village rétrofituriste
donc au fin fond des
USA où on prépare une grande fête c'est
la fête de la tarte à la vache avec une
chanteuse qui s'appelle Concha c'est
vous et un cascadeur qui s'appelle James
bataille voilà alors dès son arrivée
James bataille séduit Concha qui veut
première chanteuse poussée par son père
le patron du bar qui jouait par
Jean-Pierre Marielle voilà mais la fête
se termine en catastrophe
et parallèlement un météorite s'écrase
sur scottlet libérant d'étranges choses
volantes j'en ai pieuvres des pierres
volantes avec dans les films américains
des années 50 il a débarque l'impression
joué par Benoît Poelvoorde
qui drague Vanessa
c'est un pitchable c'est bien ce que je
disais c'est l'avenir c'est un censé
c'est fini quand vous avez reçu le
scénario vous avez réagi comment
des choses
incompréhensibles et enfin des choses
pas très claires mais il y avait un le
ton qui a dans le film était déjà dans
le scénario le la bande des mots des
frères Poirot qui avait fait beaucoup de
pubs et des courts métrages et des clips
étaient vraiment
insensé très très
original et et puis eux c'est des c'est
des garçons
bourrés talents et tellement
sincère et j'ai très fière d'être de
faire partie de ce film qui a été fait
en France par des français avec des
acteurs presque tous français et voilà
je suis fière qui m'a choisi
et ils ont fait appel pour la musique à
d'autres nantais qui s'appelle les
petits lapins de Little Rabbits alors le
disque sort ce qui veut dire que
contrairement aux rumeurs qui ont couru
vous n'êtes pas viré de chez Barclay
la vie qui veut ça ça se présente comme
ça et puis je mets plus de temps à faire
les chansons maintenant parce que je je
l'ai fait un petit peu moins avec l'aide
d'autres personnes et donc ça me prend
beaucoup de temps ce que j'essaie de
faire quelque chose c'est long vous
dites je ne suis pas Gainsbourg et puis
les enfants prennent beaucoup de temps
c'est moi qui vais prendre beaucoup de
temps avec mes enfants parce que j'ai
rien envie de louper et que vous-même
quoi
alors question cinéma quand même vous
venez de tourner avec le scénariste de
la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle
un petit bijou et c'est encore quelqu'un
que j'aime beaucoup qui a écrit et qui a
écrit une histoire sublime mais bon je
viens juste de finir de le tourner donc
c'est encore assez frais avec un jeune
acteur qui s'appelle Vincent rothier il
faut retenir son parce que c'est une une
bombe atomique une perle rail à 17 ans
et c'est son portable à Vincent routier
on va demander qu'il l'appelle pour
qu'ils vont l'appeler comme ça alors en
tous les cas
ce qu'on peut dire Vanessa si vous
faites pas d'efforts particuliers pour
tourner en Amérique vous dites j'ai
aucune ambition internationale et vous
avez même pas d'agents
pourquoi
ils ont déjà ils ont des gens très très
bien ils ont pas franchement besoin de
nous quand ils ont besoin de nous
à moi un projet enfin quelque chose de
spécial mais il faut faire la course au
projet j'ai l'impression que tout le
temps être là à moi qui tourne quand
même une fois tous les 36 du mois là-bas
il faudrait tourner tout le temps pour
jamais qu'on vous oublie puis parce que
j'ai franchement moi j'ai tout ce qu'il
me faut ici en France puis j'ai un peu
l'Europe pourquoi je voyage j'ai pas
déjà ça me prend beaucoup de temps aussi
je vais aller en plus que je fasse ça
là-bas puis c'est bien là-bas on montre
pas du doigt je suis
pas ouais si
l'élève ses enfants elle veut pas faire
la course à Hollywood vous êtes assez
sage non je suis très normale c'est très
ennuyeux
mais moi personnellement je trouve ça
bien
apparemment ça fait longtemps que vous
êtes ensemble ça fait combien de temps
6 c'est bien déjà et vous Michel vous
êtes depuis combien de temps avec votre
femme 3 mois et alors vous avez passé le
cap des trois mois déjà
ça va c'est 3 mois c'est les trois
premiers mois c'est les plus durs Michel
nous vivons ensemble depuis trois mois
nous sommes pas mariés encore trois mois
vanessa est toujours pas marié non plus
avec Johnny Depp qui a eu cette histoire
de Don Quichotte pour laquelle nous
avons reçu Jean Rochefort ici l'année
dernière pour la sortie du DVD bon
aventure avorter terrible histoire
évidemment et c'est vrai qu'après le
succès de Pirates des Caraïbes qui a
fait quand même 621 millions de dollars
de recettes comme
la suite est déjà en chantier donc lui
voilà il est happé par ça et en fait
effectivement vous concentrez sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à Los Angeles où
vous passez votre train entre les cours
de danse pour les enfants les ateliers
d'arts plastiques pour les enfants le
pédiatre pour les enfants et le parc
pour les enfants
c'est une vraie mais c'est bien comme
tout le monde
je fais un métier extraordinaire et puis
sous la lumière quoi mais je sais pas
pourquoi
on vous féliciterait pas voilà non non
alors entre deux tournages vous votre
maison avec Johnny Depp dans le sud de
la France nous vous reposer un petit peu
alors vous dites on va au marché en
cuisine on mange ils ont une vie
d'accord
vous vivez une espèce de bohème très
chic un petit peu comme dans les années
70 les Rockstar vivaient comme ça quand
vous voyagez avec Johnny Depp j'ai quand
même 30 valises qui vous suivent quoi
dire quand même c'est pas de la rigueur
des repères visuels c'est-à-dire les
données le drap qui recouvre la table à
langer par exemple c'est pas important
pour que les enfants soient habitués à
la couleur du drap Vanessa prend ce drap
tu vois voilà c'est vrai oh c'est beau
comme vous dites ça mais non mais aussi
parce que moi les enfants ils vivent une
vie de boime c'est vrai qu'on leur a pas
tellement demandé leur avis ils ont pas
l'air de s'en plaindre mais il faut
quand même pas les changer de maison
sans arrêt sans qu'ils aient des choses
aussi qui reconnaissent quoi pour pas
trop Vanessa Paradis et Johnny Depp
c'est un couple parfait c'est le bonheur
absolu donc on va faire une interview je
fous la merde Vanessa vous êtes toujours
amoureuse de Johnny Depp
j'ai toujours pas marié donc
faudrait pas qu'il est un peu moins bon
en ce moment
c'est pas dommage d'être tout le temps
c'est pareil dans le sérieux
c'est quand qui vous a dit je t'aime
pour la dernière fois
qui vous a fait c'est quoi une valise
de le faire c'est lui qui va vraiment
les acheter au magasin
il oublie jamais votre anniversaire
celui de votre rencontre non plus non
service pour savoir s'il est parfait moi
je vous le confirme tout de suite et il
est parfait
quand même bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il
est parfait il oublie de relever la
cuvette des toilettes
non jamais c'est un mec
c'est quoi qui vous énerve le plus chez
lui
un petit peu un tempérament de feu et
qui sait pas toujours très facile mais
mais moi ça me plaît bien quand même
c'est Laurent Baffie tu es sur Paris là
il peut passer peut-être
tu es sur Paris
est-ce que tu veux passer s'il te plaît
à la plaine ça ne
pas maintenant c'est Vanessa Paradis qui
a parlé de toi elle a dit que tu étais
formidable et je te la passe donc même
toi le cul on t'attend
moi aussi je t'embrasse
je te passe
non mais c'est toi
je suis pour rien j'ai juste voulu dire
des gens qui
allô allô non en plus ces idées c'est
vraiment hein
[Applaudissements]
il a la fête de la musique c'est ça
c'est bien c'est son âge
de lui
c'est un mec bien et c'est un super
[Applaudissements]
elle t'adore
elle a dit à 18 balais tu es hyper
mignon elle a dit il venait d'avoir 18
ans à un moment elle a même chanté enfin
il dit que c'était une belle aventure
avec toi mais qui passe 2 minutes elle
va nous raconter bon à tout à l'heure on
t'attend
je crois qu'il va passer parce que le
mettre les choses au point
[Applaudissements]
il est parfait c'est Johnny Depp
évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle
non
quand même
bien d'accord
[Rires]
et mettez un pouce bleu